earlier in the show we showed all of you
at home some disturbing body cam footage
from yuval the footage showing how
police waited to confront the gunman
even as teachers and children pleaded
for help inside those classrooms that
video has also been seen by family
members of the victims those who wanted
to see it that is lilia luciano spoke to
the relatives of one victim ten-year-old
uzziah garcia after they had watched
some of the footage and read parts of an
81-page new report about what went wrong
he was just a
very fun and energetic boy nikki and
brett cross are still in disbelief after
losing their 10 year old yusaya garcia
in the elementary school massacre in
uvalde he was their nephew who lived
with them and they considered a son i'm
seeing over here the report
from the committee
i assume brett you've gone through it
did you learn anything what impressions
did you have the police failed us the
school system failed us
those failures costed our son his life
and to just sit him watch and see them
sitting
in the hallway not making any attempts
we shouldn't have had to
have
21 funerals
we should have been having a parade for
the fallen heroes that took care of our
babies i don't know i don't know
after reading some of the nearly 80-page
report highlighting inaction and
confusion by an armed force of almost
400 responding officers the crosses are
calling for accountability i'm glad that
it's coming out so that we can see
all the failures
but i don't know if it's going to help
because
nobody is taking accountability i don't
say this very much because it kills me
but you said i wanted to be a cop
he wanted to be the one thing that felt
him
this was his favorite color too we love
red
to honor uzia the cross has made a
memorial at home
built with some of his favorite things
some that were returned by the school
like this water bottle with his name
bearing the indelible markings of the
last moments
so right over here put one of the
plaques that were given to us i don't
think we ever get out of the
feeling that this could just be a bad
dream that we're having and that
tomorrow i'm gonna wake up it's not
gonna be true
oh boy lily you can tell those folks are
still in the throes of grief even as
you're talking to them first
comprehensive report that body camera
footage the the sir please as the
officers addressed the shooter it must
all have been so hard for them to watch
and to take in why did they do it
i mean imagine just the impotence that
they feel i mean they wanted answers uh
when i spoke with them they hadn't seen
the body cam video but they had seen the
hallway video i just want to clarify
that
and they had read the report they were
on their second round of reading the
report and one of the things that really
struck them too is the fact that the
shooter was texting the fact that the
shooter was known as you know a school
shooter in in social media and things
like that that nobody stopped him the
the report also found that the school
administration knew and the school and
the students knew that the locks in that
room in 111 did not work nobody fixed
them and of course the police
that failed them
yeah it's it's amazing what the father
there said uh as i bring it back here to
the studio about instead of 21 funerals
we should have had funerals for the
fallen heroes those cops who had gone in
to try to to take a stand and take the
gunman out they they say that they the
family of uzia garcia says they want
accountability it hasn't it's not clear
that we're starting to see any of that
right yeah failures on so many levels on
so many levels uh lilia thank you for
your reporting thank you for being there